what's up fresh family welcome to rt
essentials
i'm mark ellis and today we're going to
go over part one of the most essential
comedies
of all time
now picking the essential comedies of
all time poses a huge
challenge and not just because it's a
lot of writing and editing
i guess it is that too but also because
comedy
that term applies to so many movies if
it makes you laugh
it's a comedy whether the actual story
is about a misfit sports team
or a murder mystery or whatever the heck
is going on in i heart huckabees
haven't seen it don't plan on it we're
good streaky
parodies and genre spoofs from monty
python in the holy grail to walk hard
many of the most popular and beloved
comedies of all time
were created as intentional send-ups of
other movies
airplane you ever been in a cockpit
before
no sir i've never been up in a plane
before
you ever seen a grown man naked 1980s
airplane
sends up the disaster genre generally
but it's also
actually a scene for seeing riff on a
real movie the 1957
paramount drama zero hour the lead
character
even shares the same name ted striker
although the zero hour protagonist
never lost it over macho grande the
film's made just about every list of
greatest comedies ever composed and it's
already been in the library of
congress's national film registry for a
decade
you're kareem abdul-jabbar you play
basketball for the los angeles lakers
i'm sorry son but you must have me
confused with someone else my name is
roger murdock
i'm the co-pilot the film features an
iconic cameo from nba legend kareem
abdul-jabbar
who has paid just 35 000 for his
performance in the film
he was originally offered just thirty
thousand dollars but had his agent ask
for an additional
five grand so he could afford an
oriental rug he'd had his eye on
the laker all-star showed up just after
winning a championship for which he was
named
mvp and he says that lots of times you
don't even run down court
and that you don't really try except
during the playoffs
the hell i don't the writers had written
the part of co-pilot roger murdoch with
pete rose in mind but never even ended
up sending him the script
because the film was shot in august rose
would have been right in the middle of
baseball season
and unable to participate anyway you
like
movies about gladiators the big lebowski
are you employing mr lebowski wait let
me
let me explain something to you um i am
not mr lebowski
you're mr lebowski i'm the dude
the coen brothers is 1998 crime comedy
the big lebowski does have some elements
that are
loosely inspired by raymond chandler's
the big sleep
but rather than picking apart a previous
cinematic mystery investigation
bit by bit the cohens instead recreate
the pace and atmosphere of the great los
angeles noirs the film frequently
recalls robert altman's 1973 classic
the long goodbye with elliott gould but
replaces the usual hard drinking hero
with an aging stone hippie played by
jeff bridges
oh so you know that they were trying to
piss on your ride
did i urinate on your rug you mean did
you personally come and pee on my rug
hello
do you speak english sir paula who's
dead english
he's joined in the film by character
actor david huddleston
who plays a wealthy man that's also
named jeffrey lebowski
a coincidence that inspires most of the
movie's actual plot
huddleston is no perfect in the film but
he actually wasn't the filmmaker's first
choice they had originally written the
role of the big lebowski with marwyn
brando in mind
other names tossed around include robert
duvall gene hackman
anthony hopkins and even ernest borgnine
i hope that someday my wife will learn
to live on her allowance which is ample
but if she does not that is her problem
not mine like a lot of the great film
noir movies they're playing around with
the coens don't really even expect you
to try to follow all the ins and outs of
the mysteries
they even tell viewers in the film's dvd
extras the plot
is sort of secondary to other things
that are sort of going on in the piece
i think that if people get a little
confused it's not necessarily going to
get in the way of them enjoying the
movie
get a job sir the bombs will always lose
do you hear me lebowski the
shawn of the dead do anything from the
shop
cornetto our next essential parody
classic is edgar wright's 2004
zombie horror riff shawn of the dead
starring frequent collaborators simon
pegg and nick frost
the film was the first of wright's
so-called cornetto trilogy
the term cornetto comes from an italian
brand of frozen dessert
it's one of those pre-made ice cream
cone things you keep in your freezer
that just happened to find its way into
all three movies
in sean simon pegg buys one of the
treats for his friend as a hangover cure
the scene is actually based on reality
wright swears by cornetto cones as his
own
personal remedy for a long night at the
pub
are you about 15p the film was actually
inspired by an episode of spaced the
classic bbc show on which wright
frost and peg all collaborated before
they ever made films
in the episode art a character stays up
all night playing resident evil and
becomes convinced that there's
actually a zombie apocalypse happening
outside after shooting the character's
zombie hallucination
wright became convinced that he could
direct a feature-length zombie film
i didn't even have enough for the shot
even zombie mastermind george a romero
is a fan
so much so that he gave peg and frost
background zombie cameos in his 2005
film
land of the dead religious groups are
calling it judgement day
scary movie
[Music]
even though the movie's tagline was no
mercy no shame
no sequel this ended up being little
more than a cruel joke
the scary movie house style not just
goofing on one
genre but the entire world of
entertainment would become the standard
not just for the four scary movie
sequels it followed but an entire new
universe of parody films that continued
throughout the next decade
writers jason friedberg and aaron
seltzer cut their teeth on 1996's spy
hard
and then followed their work on scary
movie with a run of largely forgettable
genre parodies
including date movie epic movie meet the
spartans disaster movie
vampire suck and more both marlin and
keenan ivory wayans have dismissed
freedberg and seltzer's contributions to
scary movie
noting that almost none of their
material was kept in the finished film
scary movie is also unique in that it's
a direct parody of the wes craven movie
scream
which was already a parody of the
slasher films of the previous
genre in fact the original working title
of the movie screen
was scary movie
romantic comedies of course no list of
comedies would be complete without a few
stories about love and romance
perhaps it's their near universal
relatability or ceaseless optimism that
makes stories about people discovering
one another and finding new love
such a constant part of our movie-going
lives
coming to america please refrain from
using any further obscenities in the
presence of these people
what i've warned you i'll be forced to
thrash you
is coming to america truly a romantic
comedy or more of a fish out of water
comedy
well look zamunda's crown prince akeem
comes to the united states to look for a
wife
he falls in love with a fetching lisa
and the story ends happily ever after
so let's not split hairs here john
landis's 1988 classic was inspired by an
idea from star eddie murphy this was
actually the first movie in which murphy
played multiple
parts along with his co-star arsenio
hall
anybody move out blow your head off
the film also features a memorable turn
from actor samuel l
jackson who is not yet well known when
he played the thief who tries to rob
mcdowell's restaurant
he'd already been acting since the
mid-1970s however appearing in bit parts
in the film's ragtime and
spencer for hire as well as a few guest
spots on a few tv shows
come on come on excuse me for a moment
even though the fast food joined in the
film is called mcdowell's the producers
still got permission
to use the name from mcdonald's
surprisingly the building seen in the
film an actual location 8507
queens boulevard remained in use as a
fast food restaurant until 2013.
by the time it finally closed for good
you know what it was
wendy's freeze you diseased rhinoceros
pizzle
the 40 year old virgin
i hate you i hate you stop smiling you
jerk your [ __ ] judd apatow made his
directorial debut with this 2005
sex comedy starring steve carell is a
good-natured but shy collector
and electronic store employee who has
somehow reached age 40 without ever once
doing the d it's actually based on a
sketch carell performed as a member of
the second city comedy troupe earlier in
his career
in which he'd appear as an adult man
hiding his big secret
in a variety of creative ways
oh
i'm sorry i'm sorry that's just your job
professional waxer slash actress
mickey maya was really waxing steve
carell's hairy chest over a course of a
three to four hour shoot day
the crew set up five separate cameras to
catch all the action because when you're
actually waxing a very hairy actor in
comedian's chest
you only get one shot at this mickey
didn't even get the entire way through
the job
carell's chest was partially waxed like
this for several weeks after they shot
the scene
before he just shaved it all off
entirely
you know what guys this is not a good
look for me
you look like a man-o-lantern odes to
friendship
who makes you laugh more than your
friend well maybe not that one friend
who always seems to be in a crisis
needs to borrow 50 from me again but you
know your cool friends
no one maybe this is why so many of our
favorite comedy films
salute the crucial importance of
friendship and invite us the viewers to
join in the camaraderie of a group of
close pals
[Music]
stepbrothers
the third and some might say the best
film collaboration between actor will
ferrell and director adam mckay
was this 2008 comedy about adult men
whose lives become intertwined after
their even older parents get married
we think it would be very prudent can we
turn our beds into bunk beds
yes john c reilly who paired so
perfectly with farrell and mckay's
racing comedy talladega knights
returns for the follow-up and their
tremendous on-screen chemistry really
shines throughout
the notion of comedians and comic actors
playing immature or stunted adults is
certainly nothing new in the world of
comedy
but stepbrothers gives it an unexpected
sincerity
that something like say um drop dead
fred can't even touch
this is the funnest night ever
this is so scary new step brothers
brennan and dale aren't just juvenile
and bratty
they're childlike feeling small slights
and disappointments in a grander and
more impactful way
than their other adult counterparts we
want to laugh at them
but also protect them looks amazing look
at that
that looks like you want you would buy
from a store it should have been look at
all this more
in here so many activities the formula
worked so well to mckay
farrell and riley discussed a potential
sequel in interviews for years after the
movie came out
and apparently even had a story worked
out it was something about brennan and
dale having matured and starting
families
only to suddenly face a string of
setbacks and revert to their previous
selves
currently mckay has moved on to more
serious movies about the financial
crisis
and or dick cheney so step brothers 2
has likely moved over
to the back burner hopefully just for
now
it's so bad how would you describe that
[Music]
it's not so bad right harold and kumar
go to white castle
[Music]
director danny weiner is responsible for
not just one but
two of the modern era's most iconic
doofus bro comedies
he arrived on the scene with two
thousands dude wears my car
and followed up with this iconic 2004
entry which made stars of john cho and
cal
pen and showed us all a new and frankly
terrifying side
of neil patrick harris dude who's my car
where's his car dude
yeah sorry about that i told you last
night i was tripping balls
i don't know what came over me your
car's in the parking lot hear your keys
please note that he's credited as
playing a character named neil patrick
harris and not as neil patrick harris
playing himself
he's not like this in real life folks
the movie told us that
can you believe that co-writer john
hurwitz said if
nph wasn't available they were going to
give that role to ralph macchio
also in that version they're going to a
dojo and resida instead of a white
castle
that is a very different film and
probably season 4 of cobra kai
where are you going wherever god takes
me
the filming location they used in the
movie didn't actually have a white
castle
so the whole building was brought in for
the shoot also co-star cal pen is a
vegetarian who doesn't really eat
burgers
so the ones you see him destroying in
the film yeah they're made of sword
i guess it's still worth all the trouble
b for no
the white castle chain was so pumped to
be at the center of a raucous comic
adventure
they advertised the film on all of their
cups marking the very first time an
r-rated film got its very own fast food
marketing campaign
damn that hit the spot that was the best
meal of my life
bridesmaids i'm with him i'm
uh i'm
uh no you're not apatow produced this
2011 comedy
starring kristen wiig as a maid of honor
on a gradual downward spiral
while paul feig directed wig co-wrote
the film with writing partner annie
momolo
and they'd actually started working on
it five years before it ever came to
theaters
momolo appeared briefly in the airplane
scene and is credited as
nervous woman on plane hey aren't we all
i'm ready to party
with the best of them and
i'm gonna go down to the river
nonetheless many of the film's most
memorable moments were improvised by the
talented ensemble of comic actors
in fact a number of the film's stars had
been performing improv together on stage
at the groundlings for years
including wig mccarthy maya rudolph and
wendy mcclendon covey
whatever you say stove it's steve
stove what kind of name is that well
that's not a name my name is steve
are you an appliance no i'm a man and my
name is steve you're a flight attendant
that's absolutely accurate
you can close that thank you old school
we're good streaky yeah
years before he turned a mirror on
society man
with joker todd phillips made this goofy
frat comedy starring will ferrell
vince vaughn and luke wilson one of the
movie's most memorable sequences
features will ferrell streaking around
campus in the nearby town
he was really naked when the sequences
were shot catching some local townies
unprepared
but the actor later said that he wasn't
embarrassed until he had to stand
totally naked near rap icon snoop dogg
put the
music back on let's get the party back
cracking up in there man
i could see how that might be a little
intimidating anyway he had a few drinks
and got over himself
it all worked out and we laughed a lot
we're streaking come on come on
the film's college scenes were actually
shot at three different campuses
that's both usc and ucla standing in for
the fictional
harrison university and the filmmakers
also threw in a flyover shot of harvard
that phillips had previously used in
road trip his previous scripted movie
2000's road trip
concerned a group of college students on
well you guessed it
a road trip and before that he held the
1997 documentary frat house
about do you need me to it's a frat
house
okay so he didn't have much of a mind
for titles but the man knows his way
around a keg party
it also solidified phillips's pre-joker
style
raucous male dominated comedies with
loose storytelling
and lots of opportunities for the
ensemble to play around and improvise
hey what the hell are you doing
we're streaking we're going up through
the quad to the gymnasium
who's streaking there's
there's more coming frank get in the car
everybody's doing it now
[Music]
social commentary sometimes comedies try
to make us do
more than just laugh they try to make us
feel or question our preconceptions or
think about the world in a different way
yeah it sounds like work but the best
social commentaries can be just as
entertaining as the comedies about
poor friends who go on a raucous
vacation that quickly spirals out of
hand or whatever else you'd probably
rather be watching trust me on this one
office space we have sort of a problem
here
yeah you apparently didn't put one of
the new cover sheets on your tps reports
oh yeah i'm sorry about that i i forgot
um yeah mike judge's 1999 dark comedy
office space was not a runaway hit in
movie theaters
pulling in just 12.2 million dollars at
the box office this true word of mouth
hit found an audience on tv and home
video
and came to define the drudgery of the
workday for an entire generation of
corporate drones
seriously all you have to do is refer to
a memo as a tps report
and everyone knows exactly what you mean
judge says he didn't even know that the
movie was a hit
four years after the film was released
he heard employees who had no idea he'd
created it
quoting horrible boss bill lumberg at a
starbucks in austin texas
speaking of lumber actor john c mcginley
had auditioned for the role which
ultimately went to gary cole
mcgimley ended up taking another part as
one of the two consultants who happened
to be named
bob he's the one with the mustache
milton
hi uh could you turn that down just a
little bit but i i was told that i could
listen
to the radio at a reasonable volume
milton played by steven root in the film
didn't actually debut an office space
but first appeared in a series of
animated shorts that first aired
on mtv's liquid television hey
i remember liquid television let's do a
clip retrospective about that next
i miss the max had the comic the milton
shorts ended up on saturday night live
where they were seen by 20th century fox
chief peter chernin who decided to make
a movie based on the premise
judge based the movie on his own
experiences working as an engineer in
silicon valley in the 1980s
you know before he created beerus and
butthead and made millions of dollars
what's happening we need to talk about
your tps reports
yeah the cover sheet i know i know uh
love for office space runs
deep among millennials inspiring memes
pop culture parodies and even a
real-life version of the milton
character's red swingline stapler
the movie proved so influential that it
even inspired tgi friday
to stop asking their servers to wear
their traditional
pieces of flair mocked in the movie
scenes at chochkies so if you could go
ahead and
try to remember to do that from now on
that'd be great
all right planes trains and automobiles
he says we're going the wrong way oh
he's drunk
how would he know where we're going yeah
how would he know
thank you thanks a lot now you may be
thinking hey wait a minute planes trans
and automobiles is another celebration
of friendship
and of course you're right not all these
movies fit neatly into just one
genre but john hughes's 1987 road movie
is also a film with an important message
about acceptance tolerance and the
importance of compassion
even for strangers you meet on your way
to somewhere important
[Music]
that's ridiculous all right come on
let's go
let's go put your window down you want
some
the insane chemistry of the two weeds
the unceasing cleverness of hughes's
original script
and the heartwarming family vibes make
this one a holiday classic
quite possibly the most beloved
thanksgiving movie we've got
i'm looking at you home for the holidays
do better
hughes based the script on his real
nightmarish travel experience from his
own life
winter winds rerouted his flight from
new york to chicago several times
flinging from one end of the country to
another that required several days for
what should have been a trip of just a
few hours
the iconic writer director later noted
that he composed just about the first
half of the plane's train script in only
a few hours
imagine how many movies he could have
written if he flew spirit
you're going to kill though he'd written
a variety of movies for both adults and
young people
this film nonetheless represented a
departure for hughes as a director
prior to this point he was mostly known
for making teen comedies like breakfast
club and 16
candles and that one where matthew
broderick is the sausage king of chicago
what was the name of that
though he remained active as a
screenwriter all the way until his death
in 2009
hughes only ever directed three more
films after this
she's having a baby uncle buck and curly
sue
and hughes hadn't even originally
planned to direct the movie at all it
was originally going to go to howard
deutsch
who had already directed the films from
hughes's scripts for pretty and pink
and some kind of wonderful after steve
martin signed on to play neil page
he was decided he wanted to do planes
trains and gave deutch another script to
direct which of course became the dan
aykroyd john candy comedy
the great outdoors
shaolin soccer
[Music]
which brings us to the final film of our
comedy retrospective the film combines
the classic sports comedy formula with
cutting edge for 2001 special effects
but also has its heart in the right
place this story of a group of monks
using spectacle and competition to bring
shao and kung fu to the masses
has a lot to teach us about kindness
good sportsmanship
the eternal struggle between good and
evil and how to bake using tai chi
i bet you didn't even know you needed to
know about that last one
[Music]
the film became an international hit
upon its release in 2001
and introduced chinese filmmaker chao to
a global audience
in fact it was actually the first hong
kong film ever made to earn more than
60 million dollars at the box office and
it briefly held the record for the
highest grossing hong kong-based film of
all time
that is until 2004 when it was claimed
by kung fu hustle
a movie directed by you guessed it
stephen chow
despite its popularity the film was
actually banned in mainland china
due to an issue with the certification
process when it was due for u.s release
miramax the studio that picked up the
rights wanted to release it as kung fu
soccer and only went with the more
accurate
xiao in soccer upon chow's insistence
also look out for the goalkeeper
character an intentional homage to
iconic hong kong action star bruce lee
he's seen with a number of items
associated with lee including oversized
sunglasses
and the yellow jumpsuit from 1978's game
of death
that's the same one the bride wears and
kill bill by the way don't say you
didn't learn anything today
[Music]
funding
we've just scratched the surface of
rotten tomatoes essential comedies but i
hope this has given you some insight
into just how diverse
and multifaceted the comedy landscape
can be
also whatever you're making in the
instapot it's probably done by now
so you're welcome
you